I don't know what happened with the
stream the stream just
far let's the game objective
in let's go add the game objective in
and then
um we'll massively increase the damage
and we'll at least get them to show like
what a win is supposed to look
like
so I believe we have to go get the
fountain position or like not the
fountain the Nexus position
where was the Tower data
again was it not just in
data
neutral I saw
Barracks DOTA
Tower DOTA fort
which of these is
um is it called the Nexus what's it
called IND
Barracks what's the objective building
called
four oh it's the ancient duh defense of
the ancient duh
it does does it do
damage does not appear to do
damage it heals quite a bit
okay so I should be able to
whoops I should be able
to
is the ancient called the fort in this
game in the game code do you
think doed to
NPC DOTA
Tower what why is it NPC DOTA Tower wait
what NPC DOTA Barracks NPC DOTA
Fort I think I just got to open this and
find
the oh wait here NPC an DOTA
Fountain NPC DOTA Tower NPC DOTA Fort
it's got to be this right
okay so there's the
fountain there's filler rhan
spawner neutral spawner
shop is it
4500 I mean this is so old like I don't
know I mean they could have changed the
armor of it how much health does the
ancient
have 4500
Health this looks like it's probably it
right yeah the Fort go to to their
Fort that would make
name ah so it's good guy for It Bad by
bad guy fort with
X and
Y
uh I need to just register this as like
a tower
maybe
[Music]
Towers let do 24 Towers
do what was that what was the freaking
key
called DOTA Good Guys Fort
DOTA bad guys
Fort team in range
two six
five no I can't do it this
way we're just going to have to do it
like this
one hard code
ancients
um Tower
name DotA
forent or we'll use Tower name DOTA Good
Guys
Fort cell spawn Tower
idx
team tier is going to be
five data Tower name Y and
X Tower named DOTA bad guys fort
okay idx plus equal one that's fine
how many Towers did we say there were
here there
[Music]
two no tier four mid so it's four and
four and
three so 11 * 22 and 2 okay 24
if
Tower self.
Health zero return
and then we're going to
do
bent I don't know this is just a depth
so we can
do
through if self to get Tower 23 return
true false
see let's do return this will be
zero and then this will
one
two so this is the radiant this is the
dire
One
Step
come zero
pass can we
print dire
okay now the last thing we want to do is
so we can ensure that we get this we
want to just crazy scale the leveling
damage so player.
level uh we're going to do you get 50
damage per
level because why not I want to see an
so render mode ra is
fine and I think this should be on fast
mode which is what we
want hopefully this will be reasonable
tier this has
Health tower that damage doesn't do
damage I
I thought you took a
break
welcome we are uh about to see whether
the scripted policy is actually win a
game of
DOTA hold on wait for
it it could
happen oops let me go grab the
render okay they should start
snowballing very soon unless I messed up
these damage Cals they should have
crazy damage boost yep I can see there
have been uh two towers taken so
far and Yep they're pushing in towards
the
ancient this looks like a dire
Victory radiant is pushing back quite
well
though we are at level 30 now so I am
surprised that they have not fully won
yet
Buffs
welcome yeah this is I'm running this at
I don't know it's it can probably run
faster than this as
well and I actually I'm going to put
this over here so I can have htop
because I need to know that we're not
oing this there's some weird leak
okay so Dyer is closing in but I can't
tell if they keep if they're pulling
another
Defender I think that they're pulling
the midlaner over when they get too
close huh they uh they oemed the uh the
integer
apparently or they they uh they
overflowed the integer
table we want to do more damage than
this 500
damage yeah yeah that's what we're
doing I'm hardcoding a bunch of shitty
values for now um I haven't figured out
like this is a game where a lot of stuff
is kind of hardcoded
so I don't know I'm going to have to
figure out a nice way of loading stuff
into Data
structs okay so now they have ludicrous
amounts of plus damage unless my uh my
formula is not working that
is but they should have just stupid
amounts of damage now
yep there you go that's the t uh the T3
taken here on this
side I'm very surprised that no tower
has been taken here yet this is kind of
defending no I buffed the bottom Lane as
well um there there should be 3v one in
this Lane I could put it 5 v0 on each
lane
though they have way points all the way
to the ancient they
should yeah you can see they go this way
over here
are they just getting merked by this
Tower
here it seems like every time they get
close to the tower they just get merked
they got a basic attack cool down of
five how are they not steamrolling B I
have no
idea I mean we can watch them play uh
with the human client
now constantly fighting at their own
Tower
bot yeah let's let's uh you're right
let's see
right say let's watch it at Double speed
instead of
32x we're going to watch it at Double
speed with the human
client okay
so here you go you're the
puffers I forgot that uh I have the
cursor but bu one
second okay I leave the cursor on the
screen
now okay so uh this neutral here that's
like
following uh is funny
because huh
here
so they
fight they're getting chunked a little
bit
uh I think they got wrecked by the
tower here we go back at level two I
should have stupid damage Buffs
now got one shot by probably the enemy
chunked I don't know what's hitting me
for that
much there should be nothing hitting for
that much
I should have like a bajillion damage
now as
well you can see the experience is not
going up meaning it's just sitting there
and dying right
there you buff dire top creeps and I did
not buff the
creeps I don't know why how this is just
running in and getting like
merked should be able to be doing damage
AI exclude hostile it's
false exclude creeps is
false exclude
neutrals exclude Towers is
false if found
Target it's going to be the nearest
scanned one
L2 distance to destination if you're
close you
attack otherwise you move towards it
distance if your L2 distance is less
than
two then you increase your Waypoint
and this doesn't make any sense
right so this is a big to-do
again you were here for the pathing
thing right yeah you were here for the
pathing thing earlier
it's not getting the last way Point's
all the way at by the
radiant and even then it probably won't
get out of bounds it'll just be
weird
so this is them going to the
enemies
fighting
stopping short of the Tower
right that could be two units from the
tower but it doesn't look like it to
me it looks like they're just stopping
right before the tower and getting
merked nearest let's
see nearest scan Target
it's
AOE if exclude hostile and you're on
different teams
continue exclude
friendly
continue exclude creeps
exclude neutral exclude
fine our way points
targetable uh way points are not
targetable it's the uh the entities
themselves that are
targetable yeah it's the entities
targetable I really would like to know
why they look like they're stopping
short on that maybe if I just change the
AI let's trange the creep AI so that
they just go straight up to you
right so instead of having this be an
Els we'll just say they always move
towards the uh the target so they should
go right up to
it okay it's also kind of weird how they
like circle around the tower like that
that's
funny okay so they
fight they fight a
bunch and they do a little
Malarkey and they don't really look like
they're going up to the tower do
they okay we got one shot it's one of
the problems with buffing all of
the
opponents this neutral is kind of just
[ __ ] on us
here cuz the AI is not programmed to
attack the neutrals at the
moment okay so that right there it was
not doing anything it just stopped short
of the Tower
so why did it do that it stopped short
was that our
Tower there's no concept of avoiding
damage is
there
no it just sat there and got killed by
the
tower let me just make sure I'm not
being
dumb tier one tier two tier three
right so yeah this is their
Tower and for some reason we're
stopping let's take out the uh the
creeps and stuff on the hold
on we're going to just take
out nobody's going to be going to Lane
five you're going now to Lane
three actually you know you're you're
going to Lane three
whoops you're going to Lane
three and then you're going to Lane two
and you're going to Lane
two
ways let's see what happens Tower
stun not unless I've messed up
dramatically which would be very
funny that would actually very much
explain it though it should have shown a
it should show if you're stunned I think
go it does look like the tower is just
stunning them doesn't
that if you're actually right that would
be hilarious
AOE take out the tower to see if they
move past
it
okay they
should loops
at there you
go it's funny that they look like they
get stuck there
there 1 two 3 four so a couple of them
get
stuck I think they're getting stuck on
top of the towers which is
weird but that looks like it's probably
a different
so if the distance
is less
than
2 you increment their
Target let's do
uh one two let's see if anything gets
stuck now if I take this T this
targeting
out is it still if they move their
speed and that's just enough on to get
then they get
stuck uh yes but there's there's a
Jitter factor and if you're stuck it's
supposed to Jitter
you though maybe that's not working
okay so they still get stuck on Towers
here you can
see a bunch of them have gotten stuck on
Towers so it's not this algorithm it's
the uh it's the
actual the towers themselves they're
probably are getting stuck just like you
said so let me look at that logic move
towards that's weird though that they're
getting stuck they're getting stuck on
the way points not the towers right
because I'm not spawning the
towers so that's that's really weird
creep
AI how would they be getting stuck on
the way
points if the L2 distance is less than
two
YX
Y is zero X is
one definitely getting stuck on the
Waypoint uh maybe I just print creep.
wpoint
print is their speed two
exactly the way points are immaterial in
this case
they're not even structures there's no
Collision it's very
weird we're only a few bugs away though
from having this actually like they're
going to play a full game of
DOTA
so okay now they're stuck and we get
mostly nines and
13s I see a couple of them rolled over
to zero
oops I think you saw this already but
from today path finding is really
cool it's all pre-computed
3000x performance improvement over
Python and way more than that over doing
it in real
time did you see this already from
earlier today I
forget
Okay so
weird
oh so let me explain this
um this precomputes 268 megabytes
because it's a 128 by 128 by 128 by 12
28 array it's a four-dimensional array
it's indexed by d y d x your current y
your current X so you just put in where
you currently are uh where you want to
go and where you currently are and you
just look up the direction that you
should move in a table uh it takes 3
seconds to pre-compute all of these Maps
so a map for every single position on
the map there's a different map so
anywhere you move it'll change uh it's
100 line of syon
totally 3,000 de faster than the python
version just by sioning
it
yeah and this is the fun live demo we
built a little app that you can play
with can I even do it uh should be able
to
right hold
on just give me the app or is this the
perf
test oh yeah there we
go here you are
so little
application oh it's saving a
gif hold
so here you go here's your application
right you can't path to areas that are
not
occupied you can see though that the
vectors like look at this line down
here you see how this diagonal changes
as I move
it so look if I want to say I start here
how do I get to the ancient that's
pretty much a straight line if I want to
say hey I start over there then it's
going to tell you that you should you
know go straight diagonal this way and
then go up you can do stuff like how do
I get out of the Jungle areas right tell
you how to do that
it is allowing diagonal movements
through
walls if we want to feather the map so
we just increase you know the wall
thickness by a pixel we can do
that but no big
deal we have way bigger bugs than that I
saw earlier today that uh the random
agents were like hooking their Tower
halfway across the map
because you all wanted me to leave that
in as a
feature I really like how uh like you
can see like the changes on the other
side of the map like look there're just
like a couple little pixels at the top
left that are
changing just a little bit
it's it is the optimal path no matter
where you go and we're probably out of
memory aren't we [ __ ] hopefully this
doesn't bring the stream
down I don't know what it is that keeps
oming us to be
honest nothing should be Memory leaked
here nothing whatsoever should be Memory
leaked
happening
okay
so where were we we were trying to
figure out why they get stopped
on uh they get stopped and we can see
here that they don't all think that
they've reached their destination some
think that they're very far away from
their destination as
well but it looks like they're
stuck do the triangle shapes get cleaned
up between
frames every single frame it reenders
all the triangles and it actually
reenders the whole map one tile at a
time as well the render is not an
efficient
implementation in fact every single
frame I recompute the vertices in Python
of all of the triangles and then I pass
those vertices to RB individually for
each
triangle you got to mix high performance
engineering with like absolute garbage
low tier like low perf engineering
that's how it works
um so we have a little bit of a clue
here and that we it doesn't think that
it's actually reaching the target
hello anybody working on python
coding yes but this is a little bit more
specific than that this is a high
performance MOBA like Dota or League for
the purpose of train of training
reinforcement learning
agents mix of python and
syon
reap so this is
where it doesn't think it's getting to
the
Target so it should be calling move
towards
right oh but it's saying it didn't find
it so didn't find a
Target reinforcement learning okay I see
the title yeah yeah yeah
this is fun stuff
though let me run this one more time
just because I want to see exactly how
they get
stuck I mean they're definitely getting
stuck on the way points right these look
like way
so maybe a bug and move towards yeah
that's what I'm thinking because this is
the only function it could be
in you could render the waypoints yes I
should do
that little tricky I have to get them
into
if the source that you're moving to is
not
empty
Jitter this says that if you're trying
to move to a cell that's occupied by
something other than yourself that is
occupied by something other than
yourself then you should
is what this
says but we're not seeing any
Jitter what if the Jitter doesn't move
you to a different cell then you try
again next
frame you should always be able to
Jitter out
right this is jittering you by an entire
tile
this is jittering you an entire
tile and this should be called every
frame though right
ah wait wa
wait this is
itself code is not easy code is not easy
when you're
exhausted can it get on top of its
destination without also increasing the
Waypoint
I think it got stuck on itself I think
we're going to see if I'm right or
not one character bug my
guess so nobody got stuck in the
middle I don't know why these guys are
stuck over here
there
wait does this make
to so this is saying if you're trying to
move on to another player cell or
something that's not empty return
false and then this is
saying that if you're trying to move
onto something that's not
empty
and it's not equal to yourself then you
Jitter that's really weird that they're
jittering then isn't it like the
movement looks really jittery on the
way and it
shouldn't something's not working the
way I'm expecting it to
okay now that actually makes sense that
was pretty smooth the way they ran there
and they still get
okay I'm going to go with your
suggestion can it get on top of its
destination without also incrementing a
way point maybe Jitter is busted it ends
on a way point which is not Material
there should be no C check with no way
to advance to the next spot so yeah the
if it's not updating the way points that
would break it but looking here it says
that lots of these things don't even
think that they're on their
here it's moving towards repeatedly and
not getting any closer
right this is what
happens is we say we're repeatedly going
towards d y and x but not getting any
closer
weird we're going to me we're going to
Mega
Jitter I want to see if it's just
somehow stuck
somewhere he it seemes that it's not
close it sees it's not to its
bizarre we're getting like 34s and stuff
printed right
is it possible that I have the actions
wrong
what their current intent is
yeah yeah it's like this is the type of
thing where you really need to invest in
debug tools if you want to understand
what's going
on um
something is it possible they're just
getting a
wrong not assign doubled in I'll piss
off um
we'll just do
this they're going to go down if they uh
they're getting bad pathing
instructions maybe
log it's not happening it's clearly not
jittering you can see on the screen that
they're not jittering I bet this is
going to go down and there's going to be
something weird with the path
Maps Okay
interesting try it
again okay so this now works uh this
works
immediately um
[ __ ] what if I don't Jitter as much as I
had it moved jittered before it was two
before
they're getting off of the nav mesh is
what was
happening I don't know if there's a
waypoint that's on an obstacle or
perfect oh
[ __ ] I know what it is
I know exactly what it
so yeah cuz the towers disappear
okay we're going to try
something we're going to comment
this I thought I was being clever with
this but I guess not
so let me explain what was going on
um because I didn't want them to get
stuck on the
towers I added the location of the
towers to the nav
mesh no I didn't try to when they went
down I tried to add the like I tried to
account for the tower locations in the
nav mesh which actually would be fine if
the towers like when you destroy them
they leave Rubble that would be
fine but because you didn't they would
get stuck on the location of the
towers now they don't now I don't have
any Jitter the nav mesh is perfect the
pathing is perfect
so let's see
now if we can uh uncomment some of the
stuff from before and have it work so
the pathing works perfectly
now let's uncomment the towers
we still don't know when they were
stopping outside
yes so let's
look there you go
ha die Towers die dire victory
let's watch that again because of just
how beautiful that is
ha they attack the
towers and are we going to get a radiant
Victory no we get a dire Victory I
didn't see them destroying the ancient
did you
wrong Tower 22 could be the tier three
by
mistake how many towers are there it's
uh four and then four is eight three in
the middle is
11 should be 22 to I think I have it
indexed
right I might have done it wrong we'll
see it's probably like off by one
Victory
fight go my
minions
fight that I saw yeah I saw them they uh
they got it they destroyed the Nexus the
Nexus doesn't do or the ancient the
ancient doesn't do damage so basically
as soon as they get there they Merk it
they definitely destroyed
it perfect so now we can uh we can put
the creeps back I'm going to take a one
minute
intermission looks like we got lots of
notifications that's nice I'm going to
take a one minute intermission just on
the side here to order myself some food
and then I will keep streaming until
food gets here because it is 7:40 p.m.
and I go to bed at like 9:00 so I have
to
now they need to call their teammates
useless and this is
done
yeah okay I've got this ordered H I
seriously wish I did not have to eat the
amount that I do it's a disgusting
amount of
food just to not be losing weight it's
absolutely
disgusting it's like next to impossible
to keep up
day well let's see my maintenance at
this point is
3500 I'd
say and like some days it's just like
it's absurd there's literally literally
no way to match
it
like this would have here this here this
is like [ __ ] this didn't even track
the whole thing my watch died a couple
miles short so this is 19 miles so this
is me burning 3,000 calories in one
session plus like the 2500 that I burned
just by
existing so that's like I'd have to eat
5,500 calories just to break even and
you do not feel like eating 5500
calories after
this
like
yeah it's
rough but hey gota got to stay in shape
right cool people like this that's nice
to
see just disgusting number of calories
and the thing is if I miss the
calories yeah that's like cramming
Alfredo yeah I know and the thing is if
I miss the calories then I miss my lifts
and I get real mad when I miss my
lifts I'm doing an aggressive uh
distance program and an aggressive
powerlifting program at the same time
bears oh
jeez oh that's hilarious radiant
Victory mistakes were
made hold
on that's actually not a bad idea like
just straight up
candy tum was not happy hereit
yeah straight up sugar is actually one
of the best things on your stomach
though when you're eating that amount
just cuz like otherwise the volume of
food is just too much to process it's
freaking
horrible okay I mean these things just W
let's
see with like Giga damage Buffs they got
Giga damage Buffs and then they just
like MK everything and boom radiant
Victory right so let's try the uh the
levels let's see the level
Buffs hitting 6K calories with 40 you
don't need 40%
protein
um a grammar a little less per pound of
body fat is
fine I mean per pound of body weight is
fine probably a little less than
that I mean one of these protein shakes
is
H hold
milk eight cup eight grams per cup of
whole milk so that's 32 protein in a
half cup of
whe 86 G serving probably like 80 grams
just a protein
shake but I use I don't use the scooper
I use like a half cup measuring scoop
and then four cups of milk four cups of
whole
milk hold
on let's see let me at least have
something cool in the background we're
talking about whatever we have people
here for the RLS
let's show off the cool RLS
here okay right here this is where we
gab buff them um the actual buff is
supposed to be like 3.3 times player do
level I'm going to up this to five
because they don't get
equipment
right or maybe
more they don't get equipment that's
kind of a big deal
right we'll do six
nope six times player level so this is
the damage formula so at level 30 this
is 180 + 50 is 230 damage that they're
inflicting that
right yeah 6 time 308 yeah to 230 damage
that they're inflicting and then they
will have uh 2,000 health
no it's going to be really funny though
basically as soon as I decide that I'm
finished with whatever the heck this
crazy running block is the streams are
just going to go to 10 hours because I'm
going to have so much more
time
um yeah
all
right here they go took tier one took
tier two okay now this is actually
progressing too
quickly and they're kind of just yeah
this is fast for a game right they're
only level four and they're already at
tier three they're already at tier fours
Yep they're about to uh yeah dire is
about to
win they're not required to take both
towers and there they go they
win they win at level
up what if they don't level up do they
still
win maybe lower the flat
buff and put next that's not how DOTA
does
it DOTA just has flat strength gain per
level right
flat strength agility or whatever
else compounding power of items
true so right now they're not even
getting Buffs from the levels and
they're still like uncontested taking
[ __ ] game is going to finish at level
five
oh well this is unrealistic though
because this is a 5 V one lane this is
like all five in each lane
right so to make this a little bit more
competitive okay so dire victory
yeah yeah dire Victory so to make this a
little bit more
competitive we're going to put the
scaling back in there's no minion
scaling yet either by the way so the
minions need to add scaling uh but the
other thing that we need to do that's
big that we forgot about is uh we need
to go set the lane assignments
back so these Lane assignments here
right this is now going to be
representative of the DOTA met this is a
311 DOTA 31 one one isn't it with one
maybe
right taking him
longer I was a little guy not
DOTA I played some uh I've played more
League than
[Music]
DOTA only game I was ever really good at
was Runescape or MMOs in
general okay this is more reasonable
they're level 10 at a tier fours 11
now and they're still getting somewhat
held dire's got a three level Advantage
more now four level Advantage so this
would be a steamroll in actual DOTA
right you have this much of an advantage
Advantage it'd be cool if we could get
it so it was 50 50% of the time you know
one or the other
wins interesting that they're getting
held this badly just at the end
oh there it
goes dire Victory
incoming dire victory
yeah 12,000 time
steps so every 128 if I want this to be
frames let's see if I can make a gift
out of it uh is my food here it's not
here yet
be dire Victory because I'm assuming it
will
be tick percent 128 this is going to be
Uber
the
heck this render function returns
action oh CU this is not
the this is just the client one
outcome
if uh
outcome zero
break and then what we
do is we save the gif
let's see if this does
it well that's you can't run clean p r
like that
duh
whoops r.
this we'll
do tick percent
dot we're just hacking something real
quick so we can get a cool GI
what's the memory layout for your
pathing
cache uh four dimens four dimensional
tensor 128 by 128 by 128 by 128 it is uh
entity uh entity row or destination row
destination colum Uh current row current
column is very fast
um where there's no gift here where' the
gift
go oh it's in Docker
already here we got the
gift there you
go how long is this
thing I think it's a little too fast to
tell what's going on don't you
maybe we can do like
32 and it'll still be small
enough 32 x
speed now add
trees bro you want me to just work on
this project forever so I don't have a
million other RL things to
do okay this is way more
watchable it makes sense to
someone who plays DOTA to me as someone
dota's freaking awesome dude add trees
yeah I know the trees are important
vision is so much of a pain in the ass
though for like Computing OBS gu it's
not that
bad freaking annoying though I'll tell
you okay there you go dire
Victory I have no idea why it's so dire
or biased right now but who cares we got
a cool gift for Twitter
Vision yeah you can pre-compute
Vision why do the neutral creeps keep
move um because they get respawned once
every four
minutes and they like naturally just
oscillate to slightly different
positions within their
camps this is cool though let's post
this we have like multiple cool things
and then the important part on this
tweet is that you always put the star po
or Liv
like any uh any small bias is going to
accumulate
it lowers the engagement even on threads
I thought it was fine if you put it in
like the second tweet of a thread is
that not how it
works is that actually why [ __ ] has been
so wonk
lately I don't think so
unfortunately I've got to get people to
puffer
somehow if that's the case that's like
actually
cancer I don't know how the hell like
how the hell they do
that it's like so obnoxious for
promoting stuff no you got to keep
people on X the everything app
I can Watermark the gift sure but like
it's still if there's not a link to
click to puffer lib so you have to type
it in it to lower
stuff buffer lib
we are now uh at 662 though growth has
been
awesome it's really great to see and we
haven't even like all the stuff that
we're working on here is not even in
this yet this is in the uh Dev Branch or
whatever Dev Branch or any config I
don't think I've merged any config to
Dev yet but it'll be merged it'll be
merged very
soon did the tweet that I had blew up
before have a link in it
actually I had one from the other day
that people liked a
lot oh you're right yo Will you're right
I actually put it like this and I didn't
put uh the link that's so
bad well I guess there's no way around
it I guess you just can't tweet
links hm the more you know
hey Joseph any tips on firsters
environments
oo well it depends what you
mean have someone else comment on the
thread with the link that may work that
might be good I wonder if it tracks
Affiliated accounts like if I can use
the puffer lib account cuz technically I
have a puffer lib account I don't really
post from it very much but there is a
puffer account um any tips on first
person environment
so yeah
um a firstperson environment can be as
simple as just like masking local state
observations within like a specific
field of view or whatever it doesn't
have to mean that you render the entire
thing basically if you're ever rendering
the entire thing you you've already lost
you've already lost like at at Mo at
least 99% of your potential
perf
um so like first person perspective for
instance in a grid world is just like
instead of centering the crop you rotate
the crop right you rotate a crop around
the agent and it's like from where the
agent starts maybe you mask out on the
side so you get like a triangle or
something that you can do that you can
do and still get millions of steps per
second if you want to do first person
like that I haven't done that before but
that's not too bad to imagine how to do
that um if by first person you mean
rendering the entire thing you've
basically already lost and you have to
go back into like you know 80s or 90s
video games and like look at the way
that they did their rendering and go
ultra high perf there um I found stuff
like Doom was actually pretty darn fast
if you render it at really low
resolution but then you're looking at
like coding a game in optimized C or
something and you're not going to have a
good time
yeah but masking rotating local state
that sort of stuff you can do all of
that sion's really nice
nice all right any last stuff folks um
food's here in a couple minutes going to
go get food and go to bed uh we're going
to be back on this tomorrow today we did
the pathfinding and we got these things
actually playing full games
um we'll see what we do on this
tomorrow have you tried MO nope don't
intend to unless it stands the test of
time either um company making a
programming language and making a bunch
of ridiculous claims about it is and
also having a bunch of really sketchy
language level design things in it is
not my cup of tea um syon basically does
everything I want it plugs seamlessly
into python without trying to replace
it yeah it's pretty much that
I mean I'm writing Sims at millions of
like I'm writing million plus step per
second the simpler ones are 10 million
plus steps per second uh Sims in like
really simple scyon that are saturating
GPU so we're pretty much set
there honestly the main thing I want is
I want just like a couple quality of
life things for scon like there a few
minor quality of life things that as a
not as like you know well-used ecosystem
it doesn't have but it pretty much
covers everything
else I could make pretty much any type
of SIM I could think of like I could
make a Sim at least like the high LEL
logic of it maybe not you know contacts
or robotics or stuff but highle logic
type stuff um with lots of complexity
you can do pretty much anything you want
at minimum hundreds of thousands pretty
easily usually a million plus steps for
a
second I mean the good example of this
was earlier today the the pathf finding
implementation I wrote I like wrote it
in Python edited a little bit to make it
so I know that it would work easier in C
then I you know I ported it in one shot
to scon and it was over 3,000 times
faster
slow okay I'm going to repost a couple
of these without the links
live okay will has bowed out for the day
meaning that I'm allowed to go get
dinner and
victory yeah I've been very very happy
with the stack lately though with puffer
because it's like nobody does this like
nobody's like oh yeah I'm just going to
write my Sims in scon and it's crazy
simple crazy fast and it's not like it's
not rust so I don't want to [ __ ] die
having to write the code like it's
really simple and there still can't be
any memory leaks because I'm not maling
anything it's great
very nice all right well I'm going to
bed tomorrow we
will I think I want to do trees later to
be honest I think I should do them but I
think I should get the RL stuff working
so I think we're going to get like a
reasonable Network
architecture to start training some
stuff and then we'll go back and forth
on other stuff the main thing I don't
like about the simulator right now is
just like all of the stats and levels
and stuff everything is
hardcoded it's not like loaded nicely
from somewhere and there's a bunch of
there are a bunch of places where like
if you update one thing and forget to
update the other thing you're screwed um
and it's really hard to get a thought
like to understand scaling and stuff
that way too so I think we're going to
do get the RL networks at least running
and then we'll go back and forth between
the other stuff we'll probably start
optimizing the environment a little bit
as well we'll try to get closer to that
million step per second Benchmark
tomorrow uh yeah it'll be a good time
anyways good night folks